Now the situation has reversed and KB is
entitled to half of Wendy's $10 million.
Haram.
Once you're in the grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man,
when he is sold is taken away, Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, Umrah, Salah, fasting?
What? No. Sadaqah. Brothers and sisters,
IERA is getting thousands of Shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training Dawah. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that Sadaqah Jariyah
that goes on forever? This is how Islam
has spread around the world, brothers
and sisters. Carry on this legacy of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
inshallah, by donating whatever amount,
inshallah, and support IERA right now,
inshallah. Enjoy the video.
Assalamualaikum Warahmatullahi
Wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. I don't know if you guys
know.
Um, and with these topics I don't cover
them like gossip or nothing like that.
Uh, any of these topics that I cover,
guys, I look at the Sharia element into
this and an Islamic reminder from it.
Um, so uh, Khaby Lame, I think that's
what it's called, his name is, uh, was
married to a woman called, was it Wendy
or something along uh, that matter.
And they got divorced. Okay, that's
fine. No problem. No one here about
their divorce or not. I don't really
care. It's their personal life. Is The
issue here is, obviously, we know in
today's age men are very, very careful
because uh, nobody gets married because
what's the point of getting married? You
marry and she takes all your half of
your wealth or if not all. Subhanallah.
Because there's an imbalance because
it's the the biggest inequality is to
treat unequal things equally. And that's
what's happening. They're trying to use
it with this radical feminism and
feminism in itself with the sexual
liberation liberali- um, liberation and
also trying to be both like, "Look,
double standards is very good for both
genders." Because double standards what
keeps women and children alive. When the
Titanic was sinking,
80 90 19% of men survived. 70% of women
survived because they sent the children
and the women first. In wars happens,
what happens? Women end up going back to
the kitchen and the men are sent. So,
double standards exist in two
perspectives where it doesn't favor both
men and women. Like, for example, when
it comes to a woman sleeping around, she
gets a tarnished name. Even though um,
that's the it's it's not right, but
that's double standards that exist. So,
it works in favor for both men and women
in different situations. Sometimes it
doesn't. So, now let's watch the video
of what's happened and then let's talk
about Islamically, is this haram or
halal? This is actually
not permissible if Khaby decides to go
ahead with taking her wealth. This is
absolutely not permissible. Let's watch
it for ourselves. Khaby Lame's wife,
Wendy Thembelihle, filed for divorce in
2025 saying irreconcilable differences.
Their marriage lasting only about 6
months. Wendy initially sought half of
his $80 million fortune, but things
didn't go as planned. Khaby had
everything arranged. The court
proceedings revealed that Khaby had no
assets. His assets, including houses,
cars, and major investments, were all
registered in his father's name. Now the
situation has reversed and Khaby is
entitled to half of Wendy's $10 million.
People are joking that Khaby could
easily become a billionaire with this
move alone. The private lives of this
former couple are largely unknown.
Unlike Khaby, Wendy has few followers on
social media and is very protective of
her privacy. Khaby, on the other hand,
has over 160 million followers on social
media. He also sold his image rights for
$975 million in 2024. Many assumed he
wouldn't make money after selling his
image rights, but that's not the case.
What he actually sold was an AI version
of himself. Khaby recently moved to the
United States, attended numerous social
events, and plans to release his first
film. Okay, good. So, that's in a
perspective. That's given uh, thing. And
Islam protects both men and women, which
I'm going to come to in a minute, but
Muslims
should not, must not refer to man-made
laws.
As a Muslimah,
you know that in the Hajj of Wada, in
the farewell Hajj, the Prophet addressed
Alaihi Wasallam the congregation
where they were about 100,000, give or
take. And he said that,
"What is this land? What is this day?
What is this month?" And then he said
that Allah Azza Wa Jal made your wealth,
your reputation, and your blood, your
safety
haram, prohibited one upon the other as
he made it haram on this day, the day of
Arafah, on this land, the day land of
Mecca, in this month, the sacred month
of Dhul-Hijjah. So, by no means you're
entitled to a percentage of his property
as he is not by no means entitled to a
percentage of your property. This is his
his earned money. What Who gives you the
right to claim anything of it?
Definitely, going to such law is totally
prohibited. Yeah. So, if you look at it
Islamically, when you get married, the
woman is the one we believe is the price
in the marriage. She's the one given the
mahr, etc., etc., etc. And Islam is
there to protect her.
And when that mahr is given to her, you
need to understand Islam also protects
her because of the case of a man who
leaves, etc. She needs security because
a woman has more to lose when she's
pregnant and etc., all these kind of
factors. So, Islam has that nice
balance. Okay. But then if that woman
decides to in about 2 months time or a
week's time or 3 weeks time she says she
wants a divorce, okay, then you need to
return partially full or the mahr, which
keeps the man protected in case she's a
gold digger. There are some of us here
in and all, you know, them scholars,
etc., even the Sahaba have said it's
better not to take the mahr, but again,
if that happens, she has to give if if
the if she demands the divorce, she has
to return because women are the ones who
70 80% time do are the ones who are
asking for divorce.
You know? And Islam has given this
beautiful balance of gender roles in all
aspects. However, if Khaby Lame decides
to take the wealth because it was all
under his father's name. And this is
what men are doing. And you can't really
blame them because they are at the end
of at the end of the day, they are in a
position where they're losing everything
and they can be married to these women.
All these women are going to do is just,
you know, not really love them for who
they are, sadly, and want their money
and wealth and etc., whatever it is, and
then decide to just do that. And many
females have done this as well and it's
it's backfiring on men and women. So,
however, if Khaby decides to take half
of her assets because she was planning,
you know, and Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
planned, and this means now that sh- her
assets were under her name. She's worth
10 million pounds. If Khaby decides to
take half of that money, that is a major
That's a major sin. That's haram. It's
not permissible because Islamically, it
is haram for a woman to do that, which
is happening now. These days you get
these sisters who, you know, memorize
the Quran, she wears the hijab, she
wears the niqab, madrasah I've heard of
madrasah student uh, madrasah teachers,
but when it comes to divorce, etc., she
goes and tries to take half of the
wealth. You're consuming hellfire, by
the way. Hellfire in your stomach. It is
a major sin. You are stealing his wealth
on Yawm al-Qiyamah. And you know, these
sisters, when you tell them Allah and
his messenger, they don't give a crap
about Allah and his messenger. When it
comes to the worldly desires, when
vengeance comes, there is no tawakkul
Allah. You can forget it. They take it
as haram. It it's haram. It's clear.
Now, let's alone in that aspect where a
woman has certain rights and a man has
to provide, you know, etc., etc., etc.,
for certain things, even if the divorce
process happens. Now a man getting I'm
not saying he's going to do it or not,
but if he does, he's going against the
Sharia. He is not allowed to take her
wealth in any way, shape, or form. A man
has to provide even if a divorce
happens, the suckling period of the
baby, there's things that he still needs
to take. She needs to live in the house.
He still needs to provide for until a
certain amount of time. Are there any
period? And you know, and it is, you
know, it's recommended for a man if he
can he can want to, you know, she gets
married. Look, whatever. However, to now
take the wealth of the woman, it's a
it's haram. So, you see with us, we're
not um, strategically consistent like
these radical feminists or or these red
pillers, but these radical feminists.
We're consistent in our approach. And
the issue is that anytime we advise
them, it's all hell break loose.
Alhamdulillah, that's the reason why
we're currently speaking the heart. So,
here we hope Khaby Lame refuses any
money from a man. I'm sure he would, you
know, from what we know him. He's a
hafiz of the Quran as well, etc. We hope
he lives by that and does not touch a
penny of that woman, even if she was the
one who had ill intentions of being a
gold digger. It would be a sin. I mean,
I don't know if it's if it's
minor or major, but it would be a sin
for him to get her wealth in any way,
shape, or form. That's why Islam has
come to have that balance, inshallah.
For I bring that to your attention,
guys, inshallah. So, if there's any man
out there who's going to his direction
of protecting your wealth and property,
you can, yeah, but she has basic rights
you have to give her Islamically.
However, to take her own wealth,
whatever it is for that matter, it is
not permissible. You cannot touch her
wealth in marriage, let alone outside of
marriage. Till next time.
Assalamualaikum Warahmatullahi
Wabarakatuh.